you know what the biggest movie in the  country is right now say it with me  Kong Skull Island that's right none of  you knew what the hell I was talking I  didn't know there's gonna be a quiz well  my writers told me this is a big premise  the whole country right now is talking  about Kong Skull Island huge hit last  weekend and everyone's saying thank you  one guy everyone is saying that the CGI  in the film is some of the best they've  ever seen but most people don't realize  exactly how much computer graphics  contribute to movies like Kong so I  thought I'd do something kind of cool  I'd show you some of the film's best  sequences side by side with the same  scenes before any CGI was added would  not be  the difference it's really extraordinary  take a look  [Applause]  you are going to tell me everything I  don't know it's gonna be a good movie  [Music]  [Applause]  you